so the mandalorian yes would you say
villain or antihero if I had to say I
would say antihero okay I wouldn't call
any character in here a villain
do you guys agree I'm gonna I'm gonna
take antihero we have villains we we we
we we we start oh we've got villains yes
but you know he starts in a place and
then grows from that place and I think
that in a place and I think that you
wouldn't be able to decide between the
two when we begin and I think the best
thing about all of these characters is
that there's like you know multi layers
you just never know when somebody's
gonna turn or if somebody's gonna get
pulled to the dark side or you know like
you just never know what's gonna happen
with anybody's character so be careful
who stopped you by you just maybe and I
think that's a beautiful thing about
like humanity we all through our lives
we go through you know times where we
think we're great and then we're
definitely the villains so I mean I
think that's what makes characters
relatable are there any other Star Wars
characters that will be making a cameo
in this I'm just gonna keep checking the
fit yes yeah I know what you're trying
to do I'm saying yes but look I can't
tell you who bingo
I'm saying yes but I can't remember who
there's so many yes I think that you're
just gonna fall in love with them you
know basically you're not gonna
recognize anyone we're doing a new thing
here we're starting hopeful we figured
that the it wasn't really you know
overall like nevermind I'm not
so just University goes back in yes we
can't give anything away you have to
tune in are you gonna love it
okay thanks okay